[Music]
detecting and classifying objects and
images can now be done efficiently and
at scale with the power of AI whether
you're digitizing text from physical
documents looking to identify and handle
unsafe or harmful user-generated content
or needing a solution to detect and
classify objects in images at scale we
have a jumpstart solution to help you
learn how to create and deploy an image
processing service use a serverless
architecture to enable on-demand
scalable computation and leverage
pre-trained machine learning models for
efficient image analysis
when Building Solutions using artificial
intelligence and machine learning for
image processing at scale developers
need to consider three things while
architecting the solution storage in
this jumpstart solution we'll use cloud
storage Enterprise ready object storage
from Google Cloud
compute in this case we'll be using
Cloud functions event-driven serverless
functions and of course artificial
intelligence in this demo we'll use the
cloud Vision API which can be used to
detect objects read handwriting and
build valuable image metadata with
pre-trained machine learning models
through rest and RPC apis instead of
starting from scratch with your own
architecture jumpstart Solutions allow
you to deploy and explore from the
Google Cloud console with packaged
resources if you'd like to make your own
changes and customize it further we've
also built the foundation of the
solutions in terraform which you can
pull locally and modify as much as you'd
like and while these Solutions aren't
built to be production ready they do
include examples patterns and the Google
Cloud tools we recommend you consider
when designing your own architecture for
your AIML image processing meets our
solution consists of an example image
processing service that analyzes input
images and generates annotations for the
images using pre-trained machine
learning models let's do a quick
overview of the architecture of the
Google Cloud resources used in the
solution
the image processing service can be
invoked in two ways by calling its rest
API directly or by uploading images to
an input cloud storage bucket when using
the rest API to start a user sends an
image and a request to the services rest
endpoint which is deployed as a cloud
function the cloud function then calls
the cloud Vision API to analyze and
annotate the image the rest API returns
annotations in the form of Json to the
user when using the image processing
service through cloud storage to start a
user uploads images to an input cloud
storage bucket this upload event
triggers a cloud function the cloud
function then calls the cloud Vision API
to analyze and annotate the image
and lastly the cloud function stores the
resulting prediction and annotation for
the image in cloud storage once you hit
deploy the jumpstart solution will guide
you through these steps and give you a
deployed solution to explore on your own
it'll automatically create and configure
all the resources needed to run the
solution once you've deployed this
jumpstart solution you're free to click
around and explore what services are
being used in this Google Cloud Project
Feel free to click through as an
administrator and explore what tools and
services are being used to create this
demo and check out all our resources and
interactive tutorials to dive deeper
into how the solution was built Linked
In the description below this video want
more information resources and
troubleshooting tips check the solution
guide this is your best resource for any
questions you have on this jumpstart
solution
remember this solution is for
demonstration purposes only and is not
intended to be used in a prediction
environment however feel free to play
around and customize it before creating
your own custom architectures based on
our provided framework in this jumpstart
tutorial
ready to try it out yourself check out
the links in our description to deploy
this jumpstart solution and see
additional learning resources to dive
deeper on this topic we'll see you in
the cloud
foreign
[Music]